hallo mein name ist luca und ich habe
mir gedacht weil ich so gut cod spiele
spiele ich halt wieder cod hier vorne
ist gerade keiner weil das spiel ist ab
18 und das habe ich dir nicht erlaubt
ich werde mir den sessel familie ich bin
jetzt mal einfach hier in irgendeinem
match reingegangen frei für alle auf der
map de nuke zaun schauen wir mal was ist
das ganze mit sich bringt ich kann
wirklich die anderen leute im spiel nur
warnen
ich bin echt gut mein gott da wird er
schon geschossen losgeht hier habe ich
doch direkt gesehen das kann nicht sein
dass nicht einer so dass nur eine figur
oder
auch nike nur noch hacker in cod alles
klar ich bin schon wieder tot ich töte
jetzt meine erste person und zwar wird
er hier ist bornen das weiß ich ganz
genau weil ich kenne die stars von denen
und tod denkt jetzt wahrscheinlich aha
es ist doch so leicht luca wieso bist du
denn so schlecht es ist nämlich nicht
leicht ich spiele nämlich hier gerade
kommt ich spiele gerade competitive mit
den besten spielern der welt es ist
nämlich nicht so easy dass wenn wie wenn
ich hier gegen luke spiel oder irgendwie
so oft das war wieder nur jesus hilft
kilo mein gott der wir ich bin vierter
bin ich der untermeerischen abverkauf
hier vorne muss einer sein
das habe ich geholfen dachte oh mein
gott das will auch der krieg ich hasse
das
ich bin gar nicht mal so schlecht dafür
dass ich die kacke eigentlich nicht
spiel ja foto ddp
6 km und den tod
ich habe gerade eine drohne
freigeschaltet weiß aber nicht wie ich
dir jetzt einsetzen hat auch mein gott
mein gott oh mein gott da ist der
nächste kind nicht mit mir alles klar
erholt schild raus alles klar mit dem
schild kann ich mir die mdc was sage ich
immer in diesem video spiel nur dass
mehr sage ich nicht und da ist auch
schon der nächste
ich laufe einfach hier um die ecke rum
und hole mir direkt den putz ich hasse
in yukon eigentlich weil das ist so
stressig das kann man überhaupt
nicht kommentieren ich bleibe jetzt
einfach hier stehen und warte bis der
schmetterlinge verstehen okay ich wurde
vierter ist allerdings in die luft
geflogen
stimmen alle für carrier hier ich ich
will nicht dass sie zu ihren jugend
machen freunde stimmt man für carrier
hohen abfackeln kannst du wenigstens wie
mache ich hier' sprachchat hallo welt
second slater da sieht man wieder mit
was für leute nicht in dem team
wir spielen newtown ich nehme diesmal
eine andere waffe und zwar die fast tot
ich habe jetzt die pbb weil die pbb ist
eine ultra gute waffe und mit der kann
ich zur ruhe
neben keine probleme mp 7
diese schlecht passt mit ihrem schild da
immer hat mich eine ratte getötet oder
warte ich bin jetzt wieder typenschild
oh mein gott funktioniert nicht hier
liegt die quote leiche von ducati
da sehen wir was ein lukas zudem war der
linke arm erfasst jetzt liegt die leiche
von luca ein paar direkt neben der alten
eiche von luca
es geht einfach nicht diese spiele
spiele ich hasse cod und wie bei alten
trecker unterwegs hier guckt ja den habe
ich jetzt mal getötet hier durch meine
wolfegg hier den weg wie kann man mit
dem helikopter rumfliegen ich mache
jetzt nur noch mit messer weil da bin
ich schneller unterwegs sondern man kann
nicht so gut ausweichen das sind hacks
hierhin müssten glaube ich auch noch
einige takte habe ich mir den kill
geholt und jetzt kommt von dahin nämlich
einer den heute direkt weg soll da habe
ich jetzt milchindustrie jetzt komm ich
mich wieder um den nach hinten weg
sorgten kommt nicht wieder einer da
vorne und den habe ich wieder weggehauen
und jetzt warte ich hier noch ein
bisschen und dann haben wir da wieder
jemanden den ich jetzt auch weggehauen
hat und dann haben wir da seht ihr
nämlich weil ich war wirklich mal
kompletteste spieler im ls sdsl war ich
mal für zwei stunden als ich da bei
denen und putzen musste aber mehr war
mein kompass laut wenn euch das video
gefallen hat würde ich mich über einen
live freuen wollte das nicht mehr
cod spielen weil ich kann das so gut
schreibt mir die kommentare und schreibt
mir doch auch meine kommentare wie viele
bruno war ihr immer täglich übereinander
an habt
ich grade 2